what are we watching today well Rob
we're back last time we did a Tom and
Jerry uh movies Tom and Jerry and Willy
Wonka we had to add in on it a lot of
people like deadly like you in on it so
we're like that we're doing this again
so what Tom and Jerry Meet The Wizard of
Oz whoa whoa whoa whoa I thought we were
watching the real Wizard of Oz and Rob
was gonna make Tom and Jerry's for a
drink
he doesn't be very good christmas season
is over time i watch one of these things
they stayed up for a week with
nightmares well this one's shorter this
is Tom and Jerry
the crossover you've always waited for
meet the Wizard of Oz at last this feels
like it's the short cartoon before the
real movie that would have played in
them show it before was it avaaz you
really confused Wow two people directed
what was first directed The Wizard of Oz
punted from director - director and a
sad attempt to pawn it off on someone
else
what are you doing what even to me what
the fuck thank God I had my lipstick
before coming back to the old farm how
does she look even older in the fitting
with the makeup she looks like she's 30
she may sometime it looks like those Tex
Avery you know the red-eye day
necessarily no I feel like I'm watching
cuphead right now not it's a whole movie
of Tweety's I'll say this I appreciate
the cartoon violence already sorry to
step above the time Jerry movie then why
do this why not make a Tom and Jerry
cartoon because Wizard of Oz yeah
clearly I don't know why
I want that picture of Tom holding her
and Jerry fighting on Petes with the
corn to be like the governor doesn't
look like the whole thing is on
fast-forward well I used to be an hour
and a half yeah you know when you get a
caricature done and all of your facial
features are yeah it's far far away
behind the moon hey Doug it's nicely so
say over the rainbow like just if you
get a competent yes no it's Tom and
Jerry meet the Wizard of Oz somewhere
over the rainbow the fact that it sounds
like a human voice at all i'm impressed
by bluebirds fly
I don't know I'm actually more amused by
this than me oh it just matches so it's
such a collision of disparate tone what
well Rob that's Tom's bike that every
kid has a bike chases are down runs her
off the road and shoots her execution
style like in Fargo I like to stop
stupid but the violence is kind of
create this stupid that you have to do
this sets of a Wizard of Oz but the
cartoon violence is on it's acting right
is that what color I am huh how did
Dorothy get there before them when they
were in the house are you really gonna
bring logic into this it's a dream just
how they get around everybody it's a
dream just like I dream of Hollywood not
destroying great works of art so a
fool's dream even in the animated film
they've run into them
[Laughter]
hello boo me back gosh heckle and Jeckle
meet the Scarecrow meet Dumbo
after Dumbo I think they should just
avoid crows altogether yeah just no
crows you never be anything out of it
I so wish this was in the original
Wizard of Oz just to see how they would
do a little girl fly no I'm gonna dog to
boy the odds Department of
Transportation yeah roads have no up
cubes they're maintained by the Chicago
pothole Commission yeah I played that
level in Castlevania I'd be shocked if
that wasn't trans McNeil because she
always does the way you when she oh
she's one in love Futurama
yeah no she's like any time you need I
always remember is crazy cat lady no any
time you they like always call her if
not I mean isn't that enough that we
could win I didn't see her name though
said her is Jane Goodall in that
Simpsons episode - yeah she has the
phenomenal scream I bet you stole a wad
of her she was best
- yeah no yeah just like what yeah
eventually stolen a lot for tripping oh
wow look at you I'm a dinosaur
I got no residuals for this marble men
just unusual Congrats here on the same
wave the mole yeah I just can't
recognize her as the wicked wait you
have a ball then I'm sure to get a brain
a heart see how this is the first time
we're hearing about this show to
establish this I guess in The Wizard of
Oz meanwhile Toto's they're like wow
nothing for poor toto okay guys thanks I
could use a snausage or something maybe
the wizard once pay me don't ask
questions
oh this is like some BDSM My Little Pony
shit going on here purple horse that's
the tattoo on the butt is like a ball
game
those outfits leave little to the
imagination funny I'm just imagining a
scenario where Tom knocks that guy out
stripped him naked puts on his clothes
and The Wizard of Oz somehow continues
if you were to tell someone watching
this note this is based off one of the
best cinematic achievements of all time
believe it he called me a whore I've
never heard such language know is it
should say the c-word
[Laughter]
yeah legit really good the cartoon
violence is strange on point I can't
believe they got worse after it ya know
they don't like they at least nailed
that and those another thing a bitched
out for it you know could be you never
know oh I'm sure here's what kills me
kids and adults may have not seen the
Wizard of Oz the original have got to be
going like oh yeah like that was some
addition for the cartoon not realizing
that no that was in the original I
always forget about your girl was
freaking packed but seeing it in this
friendly cartoon just makes it so much
easier ask yourself do you feel lucky
punk do you feel lucky oh do you feel
lucky
[Music]
I legit love those those are great
Dorothy punch what a nice little duck
hill tastes delicious okay for Tom and
Jerry meet the Wizard of odd this is
kind of the shit I want to see he this
one knows its audience yeah it sure does
just show a can mouse beeping that
everybody shit out of each other
[Music]
worse luck than Balto looks like the
costumes will be made from Malcolm well
this was the reference we use it you
right type in Tom and Jerry was it a
bass you know what it feels like we're
with Willy Wonka it's like people
clearly didn't want work on it and it
showed with this you know they're just
like oh fuck it let's just have fun and
Willy Wonka you feel like the animators
are trolling it a little bit this one
account feels like the writers are a
little bit yeah and it feels like
they're doing some of the the tropes
like droopy always showing up in
wherever they go I'd be it's like
they're actually keeping true to the
cartoon I just always had this thought
if water melts her she must recommend
because she can never shower
that's why she's green it's not my
normal skin color it's just algae
growing on me you know what's so
shocking too they get along in this
version but the violence is still good
the plan is even better
I never liked when they had to get along
yeah this might be the first one where
it's actually kind of funny what did
they run out water so they just spit on
her
[Laughter]
in love with this just because like it's
a really violent Wizard of Oz
let's imagine some scriptwriter just
writing C's than a toy yeah if I get
paid by the word here yeah copy ctrl C
is like sitting your car on fire
yeah damn I knew we had him here like
I'm done I'm just done but wicked witch
is dead
we could have rebelled at any point and
killed this witch because we knew her
weakness - but Dorothy didn't you know
you talk about it every day is kind of
like sightseeing you live there but you
never do and it's like me we kept waking
up there like one of these days we're
just gonna toss a bucket of water on her
bed never did it you know what the the
pension was good we got health benefits
out of it but no dental cuz that evolved
water what about the hot that you
promised Tin Man and the courage that
you promised Cowardly Lion what about
your walk wow that's like the exact same
face paste both yes so basically you
used me to bring about a revolution when
I could have gone home the whole time it
was a political strategy well the cat
and mouse have gone insane time to put
him down there's no place like home as
Tom and Jerry run away from home yes
right all right here we go step ugly
worse of no wiser a Newman okay from
Saturday night a terrible Wizard of Oz
adaptation of Jerry cartoon oh it was
great yeah I'm not gonna lie it was
mercifully short like yeah like Jerry's
terrible but hilarious yeah the Tom and
Jerry stuff is that you tell them great
yeah but it's stupid it's pointless but
at least they got the Tom and Jerry
stuff right
isn't there a Tom and Jerry meet Leamas
Rob Lane meows ah good Mouser Rob yeah
they bow sir
I thought this was gonna be worse for I
really thought I was gonna be dead yeah
huh torture him if it's actually not bad
yeah
I don't sleep tonight again yeah it's
it's at least a good time Jerry cartoon
yes yeah
that's about it um there it is well
we'll see if we have you on more stuff
than just the Tom and Jerry nobody just
really want to be in the Willy Wonka one
is Jo like Tommy G right like Willy
Wonka it's like okay so yeah I pray
that's pray for you backlights all
material like Willy Wonka I want to see
both destroy right so yeah that's about
it we'll see you next time take care all
right
you